foreign
big big news people have been waiting
for this uh they've been worried about
it and it's finally official student
loan payments will restart in October
can you believe it yes the game of will
they won't they is no longer we can all
stop wondering
oh geez all right so I want to go back
through the history of this okay
um this is from this article here that
was uh by Andy Nova back in June 20th
um so president Trump first announces
the stay on federal student loans in
March of 2020. when the right when the
the pandemic hit
and then between Trump and Biden the the
pause has been extended eight times
says here nearly all people eligible for
the relief have taken advantage of it
with less than one percent of qualifying
borrowers continuing to make payments on
their debt oh boy number one that's
insane
I understand people pausing when right
when the pandemic kicked off and
everyone's got fired and everybody's
like hey you can't come to work I get
that
but over the last three years we've had
the lowest unemployment in the history
of the United States and we've had job
opportunities literally everywhere and
this thing has just been hanging over
people and George you and I have taken
the call over and over and over and over
again and for everybody else
you have it's it's late June so let's
say it's the beginning of July August
September you have a three to four month
Runway to prepare for this thing and
George nobody's gonna do it everybody's
going to wait until October and get so
mad oh my gosh this came and then we got
yes you borrowed money and you signed
your name to it you had to pay all yours
off I had to pay six figures of mine off
it's just what we did we signed up for
it and now we're all mad that they
didn't make wave the magic wand to make
it go away and here's one more funny
thing George
if let's say Biden had been able to just
discharge all student loans
back when he wanted to a year ago
we would have already run up X number of
hundred million dollars nationally we
didn't stop because we didn't stop
making student loans we didn't stop
college right and so we'd be right back
on the path to where we are right now
and so all this is a big Quagmire of a
mess yeah I just looked at the recent
numbers we're at 1.6 trillion and part
of that is because nobody's paid off
their loans in the past three years so
the number doesn't change much it just
gets added too and uh the key here is
John while payments restart in October
interest starts in September
uh which means your student loan debt
will grow in Balance if you don't do
something about it and so if I were you
I wouldn't wait until September I
wouldn't wait until October I would
start paying it off right now find out
exactly how much you owe chances our
life has changed your loans could have
been sold to another servicer so you've
got to go figure all this stuff out and
get your head out of the sand and go we
got to make a plan and let's be really
clear about what this plan means and
um I think this is a Hallmark of this
show is we don't shy away from telling
you hard truth even when it's
uncomfortable for everybody
if you are one of the millions of people
who bought a car
on some sort of seven year note when
cars were super expensive and you were
able to make that loan work in your
household income
not including your student loans you
gotta you got three months to sell that
car period if you bought a big humongous
house and you didn't take into account
that you owe six figures in student
loans you're gonna have to sell your
house because they're gonna take it from
they're gonna you're gonna lose all this
mess you got three to four months to get
on this thing but when we say make a
plan we don't mean like well I guess
we're gonna have to just stop buying
organic grapes this month for millions
of you this will be Shape Shifter
because you made long-term Plans by
borrowing money against a depreciating
asset in a car by buying a house you
couldn't afford with the idea that these
were just gonna magically go away and
they're not they're not everyone was
under the illusion that they had an
extra 400 bucks a month to spend now
because the student loan payments are
paused bad news these aren't going away
you can't even bankrupt student loans
and if you don't discharge them go watch
The Borrowed future documentary where we
talk to a lawyer who very scarily lets
us know just how difficult it is to
bankrupt
George I
uh John up guys you riled delonia it's
just rare that I'm without words
um
please be a I I don't mean to do this
but I'm going to
um please be a person of Integrity when
it comes to October and don't head for
social media don't don't head to your
local Senator's office and scream and
yell
everybody knows this is coming everybody
knows it's coming and if you make
payment one in September and payment two
in October and the Supreme Court
magically wipes away 10 grand of this or
whatever
fine you've still done the right thing
but you can't show up in October and
I'll say this as directly as I can you
cannot show up in October and be
surprised by this they're giving us the
government never gives us this kind of
warning they're giving us four months
and really they started telling us
there's a couple of months ago so we've
had five six
we've got plenty of time to do the hard
things that we have to do to make this
thing work and let this be yet another
validation of the Ramsay show stop
borrowing money stop our money
to live well we did a a poll on the
Ramsey Show YouTube channel over 44 000
people took this poll and it turns out
72 percent do not have student loans
which if you're doing the math at home
that means over 12 000 of you who
actually follow us on YouTube you follow
this plan you still have those student
loans hanging around your neck holding
you down and here's a few comments from
YouTube that we got one person said I
took Dave's advice back in 2020 when the
payment pause started and I paid off my
student loans by the end of that year it
took a few sacrifices but it was
definitely worth it another one said got
wrote a student loan debt a month ago
it's awesome now putting extra money
into principle of my mortgage look at
that so it's possible for everyone to
pay off their student loans but let's
say this too
um we also know around around Christmas
time and into the new year there was
record levels of people putting
life on credit cards right and we knew
that there was record levels of spending
at the same time on
on what we would call Luxury items right
upgrading things and so it wasn't a
matter of people putting things on
credit cards to survive it was propping
up a lifestyle because inflation was
high and people wanted to continue to go
on vacations and continue to buy nice
things and continue the life that they
were living before when inflation was
Zero very very low and so so many people
have continued to borrow their way
towards trying to prop up their
lifestyle and not factoring this in and
this 400 bucks dude this 800 bucks
whatever it's gonna however it's gonna
hit your household it's gonna be ugly
for folks who didn't prepare yeah well
they're saying a lot of folks are going
to default because they're confused on
what they owe they've been ignoring it
and see I don't they just hope it goes
away this article talks about the
confusion honestly I don't buy it
there's no excuse if this is me and I
haven't paid for three months for three
years I'm gonna go back to where I
started I'm gonna look at that payment
and I'm gonna pay that payment on
September one period actually I'm gonna
pay that today but if I can't afford it
figure it out yes and pay what you can
pay but I'm gonna start back at that
bill don't just walk around I don't know
what to do I don't know what to that's
like a middle school kid like I didn't
know I had to pick up my under I have to
change my underwear every day yes every
day it's it's just like that don't make
this dumb experience man I don't yeah
man maybe yeah this is I mean it's
frustrating it's frustrating John for a
while it's fun to point fingers and go
like well inflation and cost of living
have you seen the housing market and
John the president I mean take a look at
this guy that's the reason for all my
problems instead of looking inward
looking at the mirror and going hey
maybe I am part of the problem maybe it
is my lifestyle maybe my debt payments
are killing me whether I see them right
now or not and so what are the things we
can control out of that entire equation
inflation cost of living who's President
the guy in the mirror and maybe maybe I
won't even go with fault I didn't know
what I was signing when I was 18. I
didn't know what I was signing when I
was 25. but I did and so maybe even it's
not a fault it's a who's to blame
but there's one person that can take
care of this and that's the person in
the mirror right and please please
please this is just your friend John
talking don't wait till October and act
surprised make a plan starting right now
it's not all your fault but it is your
responsibility do what it takes to
become debt free do what it takes to get
that freedom at all cost no matter the
sacrifice you will find that it was well
worth your time